Negative 1 and 3 halves, or 1 and a half, is correct. Excellent algebra skills
for getting that one right. When we look at the quadratic equation, we want to
look for our greatest common factor first. Each term shows a factor of 5. So I
can factor that out. We can factor the 5 out, leaving us with 2a squared, minus
a, minus 3. Remember to keep writing this as an equation. All of these factors
multiplied together equal 0. Next I want to find factors of negative 6 that sum
to negative 1. I can use negative 3 and positive 2. We remove an a from the
first group of terms and a positive 1 from the second group of terms. There's no
other greatest common factor for these two terms except 1. I notice that I have
2a minus 3 for both of the parenthesis. This let's me do factoring by grouping.
We factor 2a minus 3 from this first term and the second term to leave us with a
product of factors. Next we set each factor equal to 0, and then we solve for
the values of a. We know 5 doesn't equal 0, so this is not a solution. A could
equal negative 1, or a could equal 3 halves. And this would be our solution set.